we're in Burns Oregon we're near by
armed men continue to occupy a federal
wildlife reserve the whole thing has
become a huge community ordeal schools
have been closed for safety reasons the
sheriff has told the armed men to leave
and right now he's called a town-hall
meeting for the residents to weigh in on
it all I'm saying
speak out appropriately we can't have
armed rebellion we can't have something
into bloodshed so do you support Bundy
and the armed occupation that's a loaded
question but there cause I completely
support how do you hope it gets results
peacefully well what do you want to see
what's the outcome I've been there today
you know I would love to see them walk
away personally I don't know what laws
they broke I'm not that educated in law
I know the art in a federal building the
story is and I've been down there a
couple times to talk to them
they never broke an inner dig bounties
are on the premises and they let
themselves in and so they know unless
you can trespass on your own public
ground I don't really know what their
what laws they facing other than they
are they deplane to the arms
100% they don't speak for us I wanna ask
what do you think of the occupation
going on right now in the federal
wildlife reserve I think it's good
earlier when you were when you were
speaking in there you said that the
Bundy's woke people in this town up and
that's a good thing
what did they wake them up to look at
these people in there what are they
doing in here that's what woke them up
they're they're the ones they don't want
these people here but they don't want to
be here either but they're making the
state and they have a right to do that
and they've really woke people up here
if this results in an armed
confrontation between the Bundy's and
the occupiers and the federal government
guys falling who's these guys it'll be
be the Sharks fault in here the FBI if
they go out there and get blood shoot
it's gonna be their fault
those guys there might want to make a
statement
can they make could they make the
statement without the arms yeah they
could make the same statement without
being heavily Arnold they could but
they're afraid these guys going run off